Donald Trump is set to terminate the press
rights of the New York times and the Washington
post.
These are two of the most important investigative
media outlets in the Trump era.
And because Donald Trump doesn't like them,
he is now saying he will be terminating their
white house press credentials.
Now, one of the things that has, it was going
to be a focus actually of my keynote address
at the grassroots radio conference in Rochester,
New York a couple of weeks ago.
Unfortunately, that event had to be canceled
because I ended up, uh, in the hospital with
an emergency appendectomy and I was not able
to give this talk, but I was going to focus
on the strength of the attacks on media under
the current administration.
We've seen this concerted, authoritarian disdained
towards the media, everything from threatening
libel lawsuits to proposing journalism licenses
to talking about shutting down media outlets
and should certain media outlets even be allowed
to exist, which is a very authoritarian concept.
Even rising to the level of going after targeting,
attacking individual journalists, some of
whom have actually as a result of being targeted
by Donald Trump and the administration have
been the target to physical violence at events
and Trump rallies.
And now Donald Trump in a total gang show
interview that ran an hour, uh, with his buddy
Sean Hannity on Fox news last night, is saying
that his administration will be terminating
the press credentials of the New York times
and the Washington post.
Let's take a look at it.
Sean Hannity, of course, just gushing and
thrilled.
Hell, it might even have been Sean Hannity's
idea that Donald Trump do this.
We know that Hannity frequently talks to Donald
Trump before Trump goes to bed.
A extraordinarily romantic, isn't it?
Let's take a look
option.
That's something has to be investigated.
This is what you have to look.
But I watched this crazy Anderson Cooper the
other day during the debate, apologize for
having to ask the question to them.
Apologize if that were me.
He declared his innocence, if that were my
sons that took $168,000 from this, a very
questionable company, an energy company, and
they knew nothing about energy at all.
He knew nothing about energy and he has a
bad record, bad track record, including getting
thrown out of the Navy, and even the way he
got into the Navy is interesting in his position.
If that were Don jr, if that were Eric Trump
who are fairly outstanding young men, it would
be the biggest story of the century.
What does it say about the media?
I agree with you.
The media is corrupt.
Not all media is.
Look, I know some, some great people including
you, but I know some great journalists, look,
they gave Pulitzer prizes to people.
They got it wrong.
Okay.
All these people for doing it from the New
York times, which is a fake newspaper, we
don't even want it in the white house anymore.
We're going to probably terminate that in
the Washington post.
They're fake, but you take a look at the New
York times and you take a look at the kind
of reporting they do.
It was all, it turned out to be all wrong.
Now you can probably guess that everything
Trump said there is a lie, but I want to focus
in specifically on the media attacks.
You know, he talks about crazy Anderson Cooper.
Again, another example of targeting specific
journalists.
He throws Hunter Biden under the bus.
I thought that the children of elected officials
were off limits, but then it's the big media
attack, the corrupt media.
We need to terminate the New York times and
the Washington post.
Now, I don't believe that he is saying he
needs to terminate them as entities.
Although he's alluded to shutting down media
outlets in the past.
It's pretty clear that what he means is terminating
their access to white house press briefings,
which by the way, there hasn't been one for
nine months and you know, traveling with the
president and this type of thing.
This is how tyranny slowly starts to rain.
This is how authoritarianism develops and
the gun people always talk about we need our
hand guns and rifles to protect ourselves
from a government that becomes tyrannical,
that may use tanks or whatever else.
In the modern era, purported ostensible democracies
like the United States, they rarely become
authoritarian or tyrannical.
To borrow the, the word that the right wing
gun people like to use in this cartoonish
tanks on the street way.
Although Trump has talked about wanting a
parade with tanks, they tend to become more
quietly tyrannical by attacking press freedom,
by limiting the access of media outlets that
they don't like by turning public opinion
against individual journalists.
And I don't see a single one of them saying
we've gotta defend freedom of the press with
those firearms.
Yes, a PR, a free press when the president
likes what the press is saying and you will
hear the defense that, hold on a second, David,
he's not shutting down the New York times.
He's not shutting down the Washington post.
They're just merely going to lose their white
house credentials.
We're experiencing such scandal fatigue that
I don't believe we are understanding the gravity
of what Donald Trump is promising to do here
in his interview with Sean Hannity, there
are times in American history where a president
specifically targeting the press credentials
of individual media outlets that they don't
like would be considered impeachable but due
to scandal fatigue due to the density desensitization
that we have experienced as a result of the
outrageous acts of this administration.
This is an authoritarian nightmare that is
going Holy unnoticed and it is being backed
implicitly and or explicitly by the Republican
Senate, which is another issue that we've
been talking about which I won't divert into
today and much like with the ignored impeachment
subpoenas that I talked about earlier in today's
program there is zero indication.
There was no indication that this is going
to have consequences unless, and this is why
I keep talking about it and I actually got
some emails this week saying, David, it doesn't
matter that you're repeating yourself like
a broken record.
You need to keep talking about this.
There may be no consequences to any of this
unless we vote him out in November of 2020.
It's barely 12 months away because they're
ignoring the subpoenas and getting away with
it.
They are going after media outlets and getting
away with it.
They are terminating press credentials and
getting away with it and there may be the
only hope of voting this out in November of
2020.
Hey, this is, um, I guess it's sort of funny
even though it's not, I mean like I, I hate
that I was right about this, but it has happened
and I predicted it.
Are we going to half ago?
And it is happening exactly.
Looney Lindsey Graham or flimsy gram as some
in the audience suggested I refer to him has
again flip flopped and now supports Donald
Trump's absurd, erratic, haphazard pullout
from Syria back on October 10th.
I did a story, this was just under two weeks
ago about how Looney Lindsey had turned on
Donald Trump when it came to Syria.
Flimsy.
Lindsey tweeted, pray for our Kurdish allies
who have been shamelessly abandoned by the
Trump administration.
This move ensures the reemergence of ISIS
and I told you at the time, you've got to
be really careful with flimsy Lindsey.
He is a flip flopper.
He is a put my finger to the wind and see
what will get me some kind of attention type
of guy.